art j'apprends à l'instant que nous
allons pouvoir entrer en contact avec
nos envoyés spéciaux sur le rallye qui
sont cette fois à niamey jean-louis
calmejane et patrick chêne est ce que
vous m'entendez oui jean louis oui je
vous entends patrick patrick rire peut
excuser moi hervé oui le mise au point
tout de suite je ne sais pas où en sont
vos informations
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
gourmand house l'endroit où a eu lieu le
drame quelques kilomètres en tout cas
est totalement isolé pour les médias en
tout cas car goron mara ou ceci pose pas
en avion il y avait seulement
l'hélicoptère de thierry sabine là bas
et on a dû attendre les informations un
gain au des informations qui arrivaient
au compte gouttes qui se contredisaient
comme souvent en pareil cas et de gao
que nous avons appris le drame et de
l'aéroport que tout le monde a attendu
avec des informations tragique puis
d'autres un peu apaisante tout à coup et
enfin l' annonce du drame et c'est ce
que nous avons proposé de vous montrer
maintenant en images et j'espère que la
liaison maintenant est établie afin que
vous puissiez suivre le résumer un peu
de cette matinée tragique puisque si
l'accident a eu lieu hier soir il a été
rendu public il n'a été connue en tout
cas par toute la presse que dans la
matinée quelques heures
écoutons car la liaison est très bonne
maintenant ce matin à 8 heures sur
l'aéroport de gao nous sommes une
poignée de journalistes et
accompagnateurs et les bruits les plus
fous circulent 9 heures en vol de deux
hélicoptères pour gourma rharous ce
départ de l'étape du jour située à 200
km de gao à l'intérieur de l'avion de
liaison les informations parviennent
qu'au compte gouttes
ils on se doute rapidement de la gravité
de la situation du début
le numéro c'est l'ambassade de france où
mahler 10 heures patrick berthault à
directeur de la course annonce la
nouvelle qui arrive à maxime en avoir
marre house
il y avait à bord thierry sabine jean
paul le fur le radio
françois xavier bagnoud
le pilote
daniel balavoine et nathalie autant du
journal du dimanche
et tous les cinq sont morts
le terrain était très très plat il ya
une très mauvaise visibilité et
l'hélicoptère s'est d'abord posé une
fois et puis il a redécollé en suivant
un peu les phares d'une voiture
seulement bon bah ils ont pas vu qu'à un
certain moment la voiture monte et
lorqu'il une dune de 30 mètres la
première depuis 150 km et l'hélicoptère
mois s'est crashé bons sont morts sur le
coup et le dico pierre boulet s'est
complètement disloqué qu'elle soit
édition tu risque de prendre dans les
mois qui viennent on a fait partie tous
les concurrents de
le gourma rharous sans liaison vers
bamako pour rapatrier tout le monde à
bamako une liaison avec un temps imparti
large et
départ reprendra demain par un compte
c'est de toute façon on avait déjà
évoqué le sujet avec thierry
auparavant c'est que c'est ce qu'il
voulait continuer c'est la vie aussi de
nicole basso éliminé l'avant-veille
seule concurrente présente à gao
la petite paris dakar
ne faites que ali continue d'après ce
qu'on nous annonce nous semble normal
plus quoi
je crois qu'il faut que je continue à
évoluer
il n'a jamais arrêté beaucoup
portage jusqu'au bout il faut qu'il y
ait un gagnant qui paraît dakar
le problème c'est que ceux qui vont
continuer - voire du match porte
moi je dois dire que
aucun pillage était déçu d'avoir été
d'être heures course me sentirais plus
tôt
mais quelle signification d'annoncés de
m'asseoir déclassement de dire qu'intel
a perdu tant de minutes sur apple après
ce qui s'est passé
c'est une course qui a du panache j'ai
aussi pour qu'elle termine en plus et là
hier je pense donc qu'un mythe
le rallye continuera donc sabine l'avait
voulu ainsi sabine ici aux commandes de
son hélicoptère aux côtés du pilote
françois xavier bagnoud sabine quatre
heures avant l'accident
bakar qui grandit grandit vers l'essai
psioniques le drame lynette a
malheureusement pas exceptionnel est
conseillé de se passer du drame se
trouve en plus de celles au rallye deux
fois une première fois à cause d'un
alcoolique époux par le souligner ne pas
l'oublier comme pompier de dire mais pas
le dakar qui a frappé et plutôt la
fatalité travers d'un alcoolique je
crois que c'est un mal de chez nous en
tout cas ici on a pas de risque de ce
côté là et le deuxième drame
malheureusement il s'est déroulé sur les
tables de liaison sur du goudron pour
des raisons inconnues le troisième drame
c'est celui d'hier soir autre victime
daniel balavoine il ya quelques jours
ils nous avaient tenu un discours
toujours simple nous prions de ne pas
mettre trop en avant l'action qu'il
avait entreprises pour la mise en place
des pompes à eau de l'opération paris du
coeur situé sur ma présence on va dire
que je me fais de la vie citoyenne dit
rien ma présence ne servira à rien alors
tentons de trouver le béton autre
victime nathalie aux dents à droite sur
l'écran notre confrère du journal du
dimanche ancien élève de spina l'école
française des attachés de presse
elle découvrait son premier dakar avec
passion elle avait été nommée en 84 pour
le prix du meilleur article de sport à
l'été notre ami elle avait 25 ans
inutile de vous dire que ici c'est la
consternation
de là à savoir si la course va continuer
ce que l'on sait c'est que siri ne veut
par exemple a dit qu'il ne voulait pas
continuer ce que l'on sait aussi c'est
que des gens comme brasseur x tout ça on
le saura ce soir à bamako bamako où les
coureurs vont se réunir et puis savoir
s'ils vont vraiment continuer mais c'est
la question que patrick chêne et moi
nous nous posions qu'est ce qu'on va
faire maintenant est ce qu'on doit
suivre cette course est ce que l'on doit
continuer suivre cette course je ne sais
pas que répondre merci jean louis
patrick de votre reportage de votre
témoignage
merci beaucoup alors voilà ce qu'on
pouvait dire donc à 13 heures passées
sur l'accident lui-même sur les
circonstances de l'accident sur ce qui
s'est passé sur les victimes et je
voudrais revenir un instant sur daniel
balavoine le chanteur nous en parlions
tout à l'heure avec d'abord une